none of this story Russian President
Vladimir Putin is inserting himself into
the nuclear stalemate between the u.s.
and North Korea the first-ever meeting
between North Korean leader Kim jong-un
and the Russian president ended this
morning Charlie d'Agata is monitoring
this Kim Putin summit from London
charlie good morning what happened good
morning to you well this might be about
to world leaders meeting for the first
time but it's also about the world
leaders who are watching President Putin
is just she said wedged himself into the
dispute between Washington and Pyongyang
I was offering to break the deadlock
over nuclear weapons stating that Kim
wants to give up the nuclear program but
he needs security guarantees for Kim
this summit is a chance to show
Washington he's got friends outside of
China
that's for President Putin he now
considers himself a player and yet
another global flashpoint involving the
u.s. especially after the last North
Korea summit with president Trump
collapsed in what amounted to a walkout
excuse me the Kremlin had already said
the summit would end without any formal
statements or agreements keeping
expectations in check but Moscow has
long felt shut out of nuclear talks
having an unpredictable nuclear-armed
neighbor is not in Russia's interests
either Anthony Charlie d'Agata in London
this morning thank you Charlie